you guys came straight from work still
got your uniforms on breaking I'll be
honest with you about this this outfit
you got on we get it you say mine you're
gonna rub our faces in it what do you
guys do
oh
I'm here bro I love my dog but I'll go
about the vet charging me money for no
reason your tag says client service
representative lead what does that mean
your customer service wearing scrubs
hello VCA how can I help you you need
scrubs for that you guys out there
expecting Applause in the middle of Kobe
like what about us what about you I know
chickens cats and covered how much have
you gotten that you didn't deserve are
you guys a couple well all right you
don't act like I'm [__] for assuming
you're together yeah she was
unnecessarily strong on that he's
engaged that's weird right she's a real
doctor you notice the real Doctor
couldn't come to the shows because she's
at work the office closed at 5 PM they
had plenty of time to change